1998 long-term capital management
long-term capital management was a very
non-conspicuous name for the biggest
hedge fund during the 1990s
a hedge fund that single-handedly almost
collapsed the entire financial system
yet another world-changing event that
has slipped under the public's
consciousness
the whole uh economic system was going
to collapse if the bailout didn't happen
they got some very high returns during
the first few years 21
43 and 41 in their third year for
reference the stock market typically
returned seven to ten percent on average
so their returns understandably
attracted a lot of attention and money
and before long every bank and even
universities got greedy and wanted to
lend ltcm
as much money as they could so ltcm
could grow it for them and by 1998
ltcm raised 4.7 billion dollars from
practically every single important
financial institution
they took that 4.7 billion and borrowed
125 billion dollars to play around with
a 25 to 1 debt to equity ratio so
imagine whatever money you have in your
bank account right now
borrow 25 times that in debt and use
that money to do super complex trades
based on brand new mathematical models
that probably no one double checked or
fully understood
besides the math experts that made them
but they didn't stop there
no no no ltcm took that 125 billion in
debt
and turned it into 1.25 trillion dollars
100x on the money they already borrowed
these guys in a room took 4.8
billion got knucklehead over here
to give them 125 and then got these
knuckleheads to sell them positions
and all of a sudden 4.8 billion equaled
1.4
trillion this since all the major
financial players had a ton of money
tied up in ltcm
if ltcm went down they would go down too
or in other words
this single hedge fund became so big
that it was too big to fail
and the time of reckoning came in
mid-1998 multiple factors like the 1997
asian financial crisis and the 1998
russian financial crisis
all crescendo together into the perfect
storm their mathematical models broke
down and because they were so
leveraged 4.7 billion to 125 billion to
1.25 trillion
their losses got insanely amplified and
by september 1998
ltcm was out of options and since
everyone's money was tied into this one
hedge fund
everyone on wall street thought that if
they fell the entire system would
collapse
we can't let that happen so the federal
reserve bank of new york stepped in and
coordinated what do you know
a bailout a bailout of 3.6 billion
dollars from other major banks
chase deutsche goldman sachs merrill
lynch lehman brothers practically all
the major players
steve cohen 0.72 force 400 rank
number 36 net worth 14.5 billion dollars
2019 net worth 13.6 billion
up almost 1 billion dollars steve cohen
runs point 72 asset management
the 21st largest hedge fund in the world
he's the owner of the new york mets
owns one of the world's most valuable
art collections worth over 1 billion
dollars
and in 2007 time magazine named him one
of the top 100 most influential people
and his name may sound familiar after
the whole game stopped mania
cohen's fun lost nearly 15 percent this
year during the gamestop short squeeze
because his fun invests in melvin
capital one of the main hedge funds that
was short in gamestop
cohen was also one of the two hedge
funds that bailed out melvin capital
with 750 million dollars when they were
on the brink of collapse
this led to him getting death threats on
twitter which made him delete his
account
if you want to learn more about the
gamestop short squeeze we have the most
detailed documentary on it with the link
below
what you may not know is that steve
conan walked away from one of the
biggest insider trading scandals on wall
street
in 2013 his original hedge fund sac
capital advisors
pled guilty to insider trading wire
fraud four counts of security fraud and
paid 1.8 billion in fines
the biggest fine ever levied against a
hedge fund cohen was banned from
managing outside money for two years
and after that ban was lifted that's
when he started his current fund
.72 this whole scandal was one of the
big inspirations for season one of the
show billions
i employ hundreds of people directly
thousands indirectly what do you do
nothing gabriel plotkin melvin capital
during the fallout of steve cohen's
first hedge fund sac capital
gabriel plotkin was one of the traders
who received the illegal insider
information according to federal
prosecutors
after sac capital pled guilty to insider
trading and closed shop
gabriel plotkin would go on to create
melvin capital raising one billion
dollars with a focus on
short selling although not a billionaire
according to some estimates
melvin capital is still worth covering
in melvin capital's first
year they returned an incredible 47
in 2020 melvin capital shorted game
developers cd projects
making millions when cyberpunk 2077
flopped
and after the gamestop short squeeze
melvin capital was down 53
ken griffin citadel force 400 rank
number 34 net worth 15 billion
2019 net worth 12.7 billion
up over two billion dollars ken griffin
found a citadel
an american multinational hedge fund
with two main businesses
citadel the world's ninth largest hedge
fund with over 34 billion under
management
and citadel securities which is what's
called a market maker
when you buy or sell a stock on an app
like robinhood firms like citadel
securities are the ones that actually
fulfill the order for you
in fact citadel executes one out of
every three stock orders from retail
investors
so if you've bought or sold stocks in
the past chances are you dealt with
citadel without even realizing it
citadel securities is also one of the
firms robin hood sells your trading data
to
also known as payment for order flow
during the first half of 2020 alone
they doubled their profits to 4 billion
dollars in revenue thanks to increased
trading and volatility
again to learn more about how this
business works check out our documentary
on the gamestop short squeeze below
needless to say this makes ken griffin a
very powerful billionaire in the world
of high finance
ken griffin was the other hedge fund to
bail out melvin capital with 2 billion
alongside steve cohen
chase coleman force 400 rank number 85
net worth 6.9 billion dollars 2019 net
worth
4.5 billion up nearly two and a half
billion dollars
when you imagine a young
hyper-successful shark of an american
hedge fund billionaire
that's chase coleman charles payson
coleman iii was born into new york
aristocracy and trained under a
legendary hedge fund billionaire
julian robertson at 25 his mentor handed
him 25 million dollars to start his own
fund
tiger global management his fund has
seen insane returns over the years and
in 2020
while the real world was descending into
chaos chase let the hedge fund
billionaire pack by gaining 2.5 to 3
billion dollars in net worth
one can't talk about hedge fund
billionaires without mentioning perhaps
the most infamous one
george soros 400 rank
number 56 net worth 8.6 billion
2019 net worth also 8.6 billion
before all the controversy and
conspiracy theories surrounding soros
today
soros became known as the man who broke
the bank of england and made a billion
dollars in the process
in the early 90s britain was in the
middle of a recession and the british
pound was continuously weakening over
time
and every currency speculator and forex
trader knew that eventually
the pound would have to devalue soon and
if one could know when that happens or
if one could
make that happen one could short the
british pound before it goes down
making billions so in 1992 soros started
building his position against the
british pound by borrowing pounds from
british banks and hedge funds
basically he was taking out loans and
then he started selling those pounds
that he borrowed for german marks
so that when the pound crashes he could
buy back more pounds than what he sold
for
therefore the lower the pound crashes
the higher his profit margin on money
that wasn't even his
pretty clever on september 16th soros
exploited a vague statement made by the
president of the german central bank
to make it seem like the german central
bank thought the british pound was in
trouble
kinda like how the media takes things
out of context today
that night sora sold 10 billion pounds
he borrowed on the open market
by morning that started a selling panic
that the bank of england couldn't
control
by the next day the pound fell by 15
against the german mark
and 25 against the dollar making source
a billion dollars in a matter of a few
days
at the expense of 15 per person in the
uk
which is the perfect segue into the
strategies you want to use as a hedge
fund billionaire
these are the apex predators of wall
street they are in the business
of shorting companies to destroy them i
mean that is their business model and
they are not
academic traders okay who are just
speculating on outcome
they engineer the outcome right look at
their tactics just watch the show
billions right they hire pr
people they hire private investigators
they're participating on these message
boards
spreading disinformation they try to
destroy companies to engineer that
outcome they create
nothing they're in the business of
destruction
now you may be asking yourself but jake
not all hedge funds are bad right
yes a hundred percent it's a spectrum
there are big hedge funds small funds
hedge funds that are extremely boring
quantitative hedge funds that rely on
math and computer algorithms
hedge funds that focus on shorting for
what they believe to be the greater good
of the market
everything under the sun ray dalio is a
billionaire that founded the biggest
hedge fund bridgewater associates that i
have a lot of respect for
but let's be honest you didn't come to
this video to learn about all the legal
things the morally white things hedge
funds do
no you came to learn about the shitty or
morally gray stuff some of them or many
of them pull off
which usually involves short selling so
if you want to learn how to be one of
these billionaire hedge fund apex
predators
let's set our ideas of right and wrong
aside just for a few minutes to learn
the secrets of the trade
[Music]
soros's shorting of the british pound
perfectly encapsulates your duty as a
hedge fund manager
your job is to not just predict where a
stock a currency or any other security
is going to go and just hopes that it
goes there
that is for trump's no your goal is to
spot opportunities in the market
and then engineered that outcome to
happen because let's be honest
in this world the only person you can
rely on is yourself
and your actions so make the outcome you
want happen
remember at the end of the day the stock
market the currency markets whatever
market you're trying to manipulate
is made up of people no matter how
complex a market gets no matter how many
computer algorithms they use
no matter if they have cdo cdo squares
synthetic cdos
it all comes down to human nature fear
and greed
and that's what all of our strategies
boil down to triggering people's greed
to create a buying mob
or triggering people's fear to create a
selling mob if you've ever been to a
seminar where they try to sell you
expensive stuff
they always put the table to buy in the
back of the room
why so that when people buy the people
sitting down see all those people
getting up and walking to the back
which makes them want to get up and buy
which creates what marketers call a
table rush of buyers
that is the exact herd mentality we have
to create in the markets
and that's why the best hedge funds the
best outcome engineers
are really just the ones that understand
human psychology the best and apply it
to stocks or whatever
there's a small group who can do the
math there's an even smaller group who
can explain it
but those few who can do both
they become billionaires you know jim
cramer
that kind of annoying guy always
screaming about stocks on tv hey
i'm kramer welcome to mad money welcome
to create america what you may not know
is that he used to be a hedge fund
manager that was an expert at all these
dirty tactics
especially with short selling and in
december 2006 when the internet was
still young
jim did an interview that he thought
wouldn't be seen by the general public
where he reviewed
all his secrets what's important when
you're in that hedge fund mode
is to not do anything remotely truthful
is to not do anything remotely
truthfully
is to not do anything remotely
because the truth is so against your
view right that it's important to create
a new truth to develop a fiction
friend running the markets let's say
it's close to the end of the quarter
you're not hitting your numbers and
you've got to show that your hedge fund
is in the green or else investors will
withdraw their money
and you won't get that big of a
management fee now
i gotta go into new york to try and save
my [ __ ] quarter
your longer stock so you want to make a
particular stock go up so you do what's
called front running the markets
you dump a ton of money into a stock
during pre-market hours
i.e before the stock market opens people
will see all this activity and growth in
the stock before the market opens
and they'll think to themselves man
maybe they're gonna make a big
announcement show off a new product that
these stock traders know about
i gotta get in on this so the herd would
join you the trading algorithms will get
triggered
more of the herd joins you and boom the
stock price soars and your quarter is
saved
back in cramer's days you need around
five million dollars to dump into a
stock for good effect
if i were long and i would want to make
things a little bit rosy i would
go in and take a bunch of stocks and
make sure that they are they're higher
you know maybe commit 5 million in
capital to do it and i could
affect it today that might be 15 million
20 million or maybe even more
killing the markets the opposite is also
true
if you're shorting a stock i.e profiting
if it goes down
you can create a negative stigma around
the stock by selling a few million in
the pre-market
and just like how sore selling 10
million pounds the night before to
create a selling panic that crashed the
british pound
you dumping a bunch of shares of a stock
during pre-market hours would then
trigger the herd's fear
why is my stock going down so much
before the market even opens what if it
crashes even more when the market opens
man should i sell and cover my losses so
i'm not a bag holder
and boom when the market opens a lot of
people will sell up in your profits
but it's a fun game and it's a lucrative
game
now there's nothing really illegal about
these tactics they're pretty simple
you just need a lot of capital to make
it happen i would encourage anyone who's
in the hedge funding to do it
because it's legal right it's a very
quick way to make money
and very satisfying by the way no one
else in the world would ever admit that
but i
care that's right and you can say that
here i can't i'm not gonna say it on tv
but beyond this that's where we get into
fermenting
fermenting now i'm definitely not
advising you to ferment
fermenting where you intentionally
create the impression that a stock is
gonna go up or down
is in fact illegal i can neither confirm
nor deny that hedge funds definitely do
this
but for educational purposes only lawyer
let's go over how to create this fake
impression around a stock
if you choose to take this a legal route
that is very hard to prove in a court of
law that i'm definitely not condoning
you know exactly what i mean you induced
others to trade on information
that you knew to be false
hard to prove that you can't
foment you can't create a yourself
an impression that a stock's down but
you do it anyway because the sec doesn't
understand it so
yeah i mean it's that's the only sense
that i would say this is illegal but a
hedge fund
that's not up a lot really has to do a
lot now to save itself so
this is actually just a blatantly
illegal but when you have six days and
your company may be in doubt because
you're down i think it's really
important to ferment
uh if i were one of these guys this is
actually just a blatantly illegal but i
think it's really important
to ferment uh if i were one analysts
have you ever wondered why stock
analysts the people who predict whether
you should buy hold or sell a stock
never have a hit percentage next to them
like a percentage on how accurate their
predictions have been in the past kind
of like how baseball players have their
stats
it's because they would be out of a job
because they're usually wrong
and yet they still hold a ton of
influence over the market don't ask me
why
especially in smaller stocks people
still take them seriously
which makes analysts a great tool for
our manipulation
since analysts work for hedge funds
investment banks etc
they can't bite the hand that feeds them
so if you want to buy a stock or you're
shorting a stock
you can theoretically have analysts
downgrade that stock
if you want to sell a stock at a higher
price you can have analysts
theoretically upgrade that stock
a lot of analysts work for investment
banks or banking sectors of some kind
or supported indirectly by investment
banks right analysts are supposed to be
independent most of the time but give me
a break these analysts are getting the
checks cut by the investment banks
so do you think the investment banks are
really going to go against
what their short shareholders and what
their
investments are in journalists
journalists are arguably even more
powerful than analysts
because if a journalist publishes a news
story about stock
people outside of wall street are
influenced as well and journalists
are also very easy to manipulate if you
want a stock to go down
journalists have an incentive to publish
bad news because bad news gets more
clicks more clicks equals more money for
the publication
more money for their employer equals
better career prospects for them
this is coming from personal experience
as a youtuber kinda like what we're
doing in this video
and this is very easy because the people
who write about apple want that story
and you can claim that it's credible
because you spoke to someone at apple
because apple isn't and it
doesn't right they're not going to
comment you can leak a juicy story to a
journalist directly
then you would call the journal and you
get the bozo reporter or you can spread
it to others on wall street knowing that
it will eventually make its way to a
journalist
and the way you would do that is you
pick up the phone you call six trading
disks and say listen i just
got the phone with my contact there's no
room for apple they want too much that
we're not gonna let them in
this is not we're not gonna let them do
what they did to music and you know i
think that's a very effective way to
keep a stock down right
anonymous articles let's say you're even
lazier than that
you don't want to deal with journalists
or you want to avoid any potential
lawsuits or damage to your reputation
an even easier route you can take is to
post anonymous hit pieces about
companies on influential websites like
seeking alpha
now this may sound kind of silly like
who in their right mind would base their
investments on anonymous articles on the
internet
but the results speak for themselves
december 2015
anonymous short seller investor for
truth pushes united development funding
4 down 35
after much speculation kyle bass of
hayman capital management reveals that
investor for truth is him
ironically kyle bass has been featured
on this channel
bank of california an anonymous article
by short seller aurelius caused the
stock to plummet by 29
the ceo and vice chairman stepping down
and the sec initiating an investigation
all from one anonymous article bank of
the internet has been the subject of
around 30 short seller pieces over three
and a half years
bringing it down as far as 37 percent
arrows international
short attacks pushed the indian
bollywood filmmaker down 50 percent
acoustics technologies short attacks
push it down 43
at one point why does this work because
you don't need to convince a lot of
people
all you need to do is to instill a
little bit of doubt in some
they will sell maybe some journalists
will pick up the story giving it
credibility
which will cause other people to sell
which will trigger a domino effect of
herd selling
and next thing you know a stock is down
50 thanks to a few anonymous articles
making you at least a 50 return and
maybe if you borrow some money to trade
with ie trading on margin
you can make upwards of a hundred
percent on just one short attack
and the best part about all these
strategies it's that it's hard to prove
and the sec are too incompetent to prove
it the way that the market really works
is to
is to have that nexus of i've hit the
brokerage houses with a series of orders
that can push it down
then leak it to the press and then get
it on cnbc that's also very important
and then you have a kind of a vicious
cycle damn right it's a pretty good game
these are all the things you must do on
a day like today and if you're not doing
it maybe you shouldn't be in the game
so tran capital our venture capital firm
will now be opening up its own hedge
fund division
and we will be employing all the tactics
we went over in this video so that you
know
your money is getting put to good
productive use if you are new here and
you want more dark sarcasm and only the
best
video essays on the most provocative
thought-provoking stuff in the world of
business just like this one
there is a red button below that says
subscribe that you can click for more
free videos just like this every single
week
and the best part is that you can
dislike unsubscribe leaving your best
hate comments whenever you want so you
have nothing to lose
and everything to gain and you can also
turn on that notification bell to get
notified when new videos come out
if you want business memes behind the
scenes stuff day in the life kind of
stuff you can follow me on instagram at
jtrend.io where we have a ton of fun
over there that is going to wrap it up
for this video thank you so much for
watching
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
you